les emmys c'était cette nuit à los
angeles avec the good doctor zendaya
andrew garfield ben stiller coucou et
s'était présentée par un des piliers du
saturday night live kenan thompson
d'abord une chose extraordinaire
n'oublie pas et n'oublie jamais que je
t'aime tu entends michel mais moi aussi
mon qui jean luc et il va suis je
revivais cela les quatre fois 20 ans
hier ouais
et comme dirait venir parfois qu étant
plus raté votre vie parce qu'il y avait
un moyen de gagner beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup plus que la télé
s'être influenceurs alors ça c'est à
dubaï
autant je n'ai pas
peur et michel carnation voilà et cherré
dubaï ça ça me fait beaucoup rire mais
c'est incroyable c'est le paradis du
vite que c'est ça qui est formidable
depuis mars 2 qui kim kardashian et elle
officiellement divorcés pauline haas
assez de la classe à bas voilà trois
points pour les bleus
tu es magnifique ya la queue et où
j'avais pas vu je suis assis à côté des
otages n'avait pas vu mais pas vu là que
j'avais déjà dit cette phrase lors d'un
voyage au brésil ya quelques années
celui qui pense pouvoir reconnaître le
plus d'animaux de mon album photo sur le
seul qui joue
le s anagramme de disputer synonyme d'
idiot
stupide et oui mais trop tard moi c'est
la femme du chef mai 10 19 19 la wii et
wii
dix neuf animaux ces
séjours un challenge en avait 19 à les
fatiguer en corner
[Applaudissements]
il a eu peur et je les vois là mais j'ai
pas eu peur de la surprise visuelle
est enfin vanté je m'ennuie vite que toi
mais je sais que
les surprises on a eu le droit à des
discours vraiment sincère comme celui-ci
ce match
l'actrice jean smart aussi avait l'air
un peu figé mais c'était pas pour les
mêmes raisons
et c'est ball trap et nestlé brio à
genève ibrahim traoré
allez
c'est l'immense francis huster senozan
et c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui suis chargé de trouver
trois raisons que vous aimez jean-paul
écoute moi y'en a une énorme on vous
aime parce que vous avez touché des
français
non faux pas ne faut pas réagir faut
écouter est très intéressant faut
vraiment écouté
joli ça elle la trouve très simple comme
ça
ça en réunion vous dis ça et puis elle
dit que j'ai trouvé ça c'est un bon
parcours on a faim on a besoin de toi
marie claude mercier mon cher et je
t'aime comme un travail tactique je
t'aime et je sais que j'ai toujours été
là prouver et je le serai toujours voilà
parce que tu es d'accord quelqu'un que
j'aime et si je d'un moteur famille avec
grand plaisir
pour garder ce micro d'argent pour
chanter pour 20000 euros de chansons de
johnny
que je t'aime en 69
c'est la députée l'année un jour tu
paieras pour tout ça mais je ne fais que
donner des informations chacun fait ce
qu'il veut tu seras jugé zendaya qui est
au passage devenue la plus jeune actrice
avoir remporté 2 émise puisqu'elle vient
de fêter ses 26 ans
dans un instant je vous présente juste
répéter à beaufour chef propriétaire du
restaurant dans ces paradis à paris on
soit avec des canaux qui est un jeu qui
a réduit à souhait je suis en faisant
défiler retard c'est quoi le truc on
fait les gnocchis récit sort est entre
les deux au départ une prononciation
j'aime la cuisine familiale la cuisine
m
[Musique]
torchon de l'eau
permettre aux centres de formation sur
mon travail
premier revers spatiale pour jeff bezos
le fondateur d'amazon le lanceur de la
fusée de tourisme blue origin s'est
écrasé hier dans l'ouest du texas après
son décollage sans faire de blessé il
s'agissait de sa 23e mission c'est la
première à se solder par un échec dû à
un dysfonctionnement indique
l'entreprise la capsule non habitée en
portait uniquement du matériel de
recherche pour cette mission